Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）共同发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。挑战赛还有由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent, clinical psychologist, and it's lovely to have you here listening. Thank you so much to everybody who's been so welcoming and enthusiastic and encouraging about the new book that was published last week, The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. It's really lovely to see so many of you excited to get your hands on it and to read it. So I do hope that you're finding that useful if you've got your copy already. If you haven't, there is always time, always time, but why not dive in and do that now? You can grab that on Amazon and it's available in paperback, ebook or hardback. The hardback is in full colour, which is why the price is a little bit steeper than might be ideal. I thought it would be nice to put together a hardback colour
我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特博士，很高兴你能在这里收听。非常感谢大家对上周出版的新书《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）所表现出的热情、欢迎和鼓励。看到这么多朋友对这本书感到兴奋并渴望阅读，我真的感到非常高兴。如果你已经拿到了书，希望你觉得它很有用。如果你还没买，现在买也完全来得及，为什么不现在就行动呢？你可以在亚马逊上购买，有平装版、电子书版和精装版。精装版是全彩印刷的，所以价格比预期的要高一些。我当时觉得制作一本精装彩色版会很不错，
option because they don't let you do a paperback black and white and a paperback colour. But I didn't quite realise how expensive it would be to make it colour. So it is a thing of beauty. You can also get colour in the e-book, but the hardback is in glorious Technicolour. It is a thing of beauty so um if your department has some spare cash or um you know you've got someone who wants to spend a little bit of money on you for christmas then the hardback is lovely um but the content is all the same apart from the color so take your pick see what works best for you paperback ebook or hardback. If you would like to enter into a competition to win a one-to-one psychology coaching session with me, you absolutely can do by buying a copy of either
因为平台不支持同时发布黑白平装版和彩色平装版。但我没意识到彩色印刷的成本会这么高。所以它确实是一件精美的作品。电子书版也是彩色的，但精装版是绚丽的彩色印刷。它真的很美，所以如果你的部门有预算，或者你有朋友想在圣诞节为你买份礼物，精装版会是非常棒的选择。除了颜色不同，内容都是一样的，所以你可以根据自己的喜好选择平装版、电子书版或精装版。如果你想参加抽奖，赢取与我进行一对一心理学辅导的机会，你完全可以通过购买
the Clinical Psychologist Collective book between the 1st of September 2022 and Halloween the 31st of October 2022 and then sending me a unique proof of purchase to book at goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and the details for that email address in case you missed it are in the show notes but it's book at goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and you can also score some bonus point entries as well if you did buy it on amazon then you can leave me a verified purchase review and then send me proof of that once it's done and you don't you could have bought the clin psych or the aspiring psychologist collective book at any time but by doing the review for me within this period means that you can enter the contest if you let me know
《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）或《有抱负的心理学家集体》中的任意一本，购买时间需在2022年9月1日至2022年10月31日（万圣节）之间，然后将购买凭证发送至 book@goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk。如果你错过了，这个邮箱地址就在节目说明里。你还可以获得额外的抽奖机会：如果你是在亚马逊上购买的，可以留下经过验证的购买评论，然后将评论截图发给我。无论你是什么时候买的这两本书，只要在这段时间内为我写评论，就可以参加比赛。
between that bracket of the 1st of September and the 31st of October. And you can also score some bonus entries by leaving the audio testimonials about either the Clinical Psychologist Collective book or the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. or if you bought them both, you could do both. That would be marvellous. And you could get two bonus entries. It is super simple to leave me audio testimonials. If you go to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast, you just click on a link which opens a wonderful site called Bonjouro and it literally is just point and click. You know, you just pop your name in, pop your webcam on and go for it. But you can cover your webcam if you don't want it to be a video testimonial. If you're just happy for it to be audio, then do that.
只要在9月1日到10月31日之间告知我即可。你还可以通过留下关于《临床心理学家集体》或《有抱负的心理学家集体》的音频感言来获得额外抽奖机会。如果你两本都买了，也可以两本都评价，那太棒了，你可以获得两次额外抽奖机会。留下音频感言非常简单。访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast，点击链接进入一个叫 Bonjouro 的网站，操作非常简单，只需点击即可。输入你的名字，打开摄像头就可以录制了。如果你不想露脸，也可以遮住摄像头，只录制音频。
But you need to do that and you need to get it done before the 31st of October because that is when the contest ends and you could use this session if you win which will take place on the 1st, 2nd or 3rd of November to think about your doctorate in clinical psychology application form or another professional psychology application form or if you're qualified or not yet ready to apply, we could use that for thinking about just coaching and ways to help you be your optimal best self. So dive in and, yeah, take advantage and enter the competition. Right. So as you may have noticed, I do have lots of plates spinning. So for those of you who followed me on the podcast for a while, you might well know that I am a mummy. I'm a mummy to two young children. I'm also a clinician still.
但你需要在10月31日之前完成，因为那是比赛截止日期。如果你赢了，我们将于11月1日、2日或3日进行辅导，内容可以讨论你的临床心理学博士申请表或其他专业心理学申请表。如果你已经获得资格或还没准备好申请，我们也可以利用这段时间进行职业辅导，探讨如何让你成为最佳状态的自己。所以，快来参加比赛吧。好了，正如你可能注意到的，我手头有很多事情要忙。对于那些关注我播客一段时间的朋友，你们可能知道我是一位妈妈。我有两个年幼的孩子，同时我仍然是一名临床医生。
So I do still see people for one to one trauma therapy usually, but also do anxiety, depression and grief too. So I do that. But I also support aspiring psychologists, you lovely folk. And I also create books, don't I? And so, you know, people are like, Marianne, how do you get enough time in the day? How do you organise yourself to get everything done, to get everything sorted? And so I thought that would be a really useful conversation for us to have together today about ways we can organise ourselves or help support ourselves optimally to be our best, energetic, energised, productive selves so um I've no idea how long today's podcast episode is going to be I've got a vague idea of um the top tips that I'm going to go through written myself a list
所以我通常还会进行一对一的创伤治疗，也处理焦虑、抑郁和悲伤等问题。我不仅做这些，还支持你们这些可爱的有抱负的心理学家。我还在写书，对吧？所以人们常问我：“玛丽安，你一天怎么有那么多时间？你是怎么安排自己把所有事情都处理好的？”所以我认为今天我们一起讨论一下如何组织自己，或者如何支持自己，以达到最佳、最有活力、最高效的状态，这会非常有意义。我不知道今天的播客会录多久，我列了一个清单，上面写着我要讲的要点，
um which I've left just out of my reach um so I'm going to grab my list hold the line caller seamless I'm back and I've got the list um so um one of my main strategies for organizing myself for kind of making sense of what might feel like organized chaos if it wasn't for this one super duper top tip um is that I used to work in a service which employed the choice and partnership approach also abbreviated often as CAPA and I know that still runs in certain children and young people's services which is which was the type of service that I was working in and in that service it worked wonderfully for us because we were all quite compliant with the different ways of working. But in case you haven't heard of a CAPA service, let me briefly go through the basic tenets for that. So depending
但我刚才把清单放在够不着的地方了。稍等一下，我这就去拿。好了，我回来了，清单在手。那么，我组织自己、理清那些看似混乱的生活的主要策略之一，就是我曾经在一家采用“选择与伙伴关系方法”（Choice and Partnership Approach，简称 CAPA）的服务机构工作。我知道这种方法在某些儿童和青少年服务机构中仍在运行，那也是我当时工作的机构类型。在那家机构里，这种方法对我们非常有效，因为我们都非常配合这种工作方式。如果你没听说过 CAPA 服务，让我简要介绍一下它的基本原则。
on how many hours a week you work, it is closely calculated for how many clinical face-to-face hours it is expected of you to be able to do to be, you know, working at your full capacity. And you pick up new clients at a set ratio depending on your hours. So when I first started with the team, I was full-time and that meant that I would, for three weeks out of four I would pick up a new client and it's always in the same slot so for me it was a Thursday at 2 p.m so for three out of the four and if it was five Thursdays in a month it was three out of five for three out of those four or five Thursdays I would pick up a new client. And that's not a client that I'm choosing to see. That was a client that following assessment, following the choice
根据你每周的工作时长，系统会精确计算出你预计需要完成的临床面对面工作时长，以确保你处于满负荷工作状态。你会根据工作时长按固定比例接收新客户。我刚加入团队时是全职的，这意味着在四周里有三周我会接收一名新客户，而且时间是固定的，对我来说是周四下午2点。所以在那四周或五周的周四里，有三周我会接收一名新客户。那不是我选择要见的客户，而是经过评估和“选择预约”（Choice appointment）后，如果他们被认为需要这项服务，就会被分配给下一位有空的临床医生。那可能是我，也可能是团队里的其他人。
appointment, which was an assessment, if they were deemed to need the service, then they were dropped in with the next available choice clinician. So that might have been me, but it could have been someone else in the team as well. So I always knew that I had to be having throughput, had to be not a long-term service, but people were always having a goals-based service. But what was really useful about this service was that all of the clinicians had job plans that were unique and bespoke to them. And those job plans helped us to make sure we were using the available rooms optimally as well. So as I reflect back on that now, there were certain times in certain clinics, certainly Thursday afternoons, I had set rooms. I always quite like the same room as well so they'd be kind to me give me the same room creature of habit where possible
所以我总是知道我必须保持工作量，这不是一个长期服务，人们接受的是基于目标的服务。这种服务最有用的一点是，所有临床医生都有独特且量身定制的工作计划。这些计划帮助我们确保房间资源也得到了最优利用。回想起来，在某些诊所的特定时间，比如周四下午，我有固定的房间。我总是喜欢用同一个房间，因为我习惯了，如果可能的话，他们会尽量满足我。
and you know there were set clinics so I would always do choice assessments on a Wednesday morning so I would do in my job plan two choice appointments. So one was at 9.30 and one was at 11. And then I would use the afternoon of that time usually to write those reports. So they were all done and dusted within the same day. But that was all blocked in. Admin time for the choice appointments was in my job plan. So it wasn't like I was trying to magically create time for admin. It was there. Okay. And similarly, a Friday afternoon, for me, seeing clients on a Friday afternoon, where you might suddenly get a safeguarding issue at 4pm, and I finished at 4.30 because of my commute, that was not for me. So I made sure in my job plan that I had a clinic with rooms booked on a Friday morning, but on a Friday afternoon
而且诊所的时间是固定的，所以我总是会在周三上午进行“选择评估”，我的工作计划里安排了两次选择预约，一次是9:30，一次是11:00。然后我通常会利用那天下午的时间写报告，这样当天就能全部完成。这些时间都是预留好的。选择预约的行政时间也包含在我的工作计划中，所以我不需要费力去挤时间处理行政工作，时间就在那里。同样，周五下午对我来说不适合见客户，因为你可能会在下午4点突然遇到紧急保护问题，而我因为通勤需要在4:30下班。所以我确保在工作计划中，周五上午安排诊所和房间，而周五下午
that was administration for issues related to my clients. If I was writing letters or if there was any additional referrals that I needed to use to write for the choice appointments for the assessment. So I know it can be common in services where we're doing assessments that we just haven't been able to factor in the time to write reports. But if that's the case, you know, I think we're potentially setting ourselves up to fail and to be feeling quite overwhelmed and distressed and to feel like we're not managing, we're not coping, there's too much on our plate. So if you're regularly doing assessments or perhaps supporting qualified members of staff with assessments and then helping out with the assessment report writing. There needs to be
专门用于处理与客户相关的行政工作，比如写信，或者处理评估所需的额外转诊。我知道在进行评估的服务机构中，没时间写报告是很常见的。但如果是这样，我认为我们是在为失败做准备，会感到不知所措、痛苦，觉得无法应对，负担过重。所以如果你经常进行评估，或者协助有资质的员工进行评估并帮忙写报告，你的日程表中必须有专门的时间来做这些，否则你将不得不不断地挤占午餐时间、提前开始或推迟下班时间来完成工作。所以，请审视你每周的工作内容。同样，督导也应该包含在你的工作计划中，并且是一个持续、可重复的过程。
time in your diary where you're going to do that otherwise you're going to be constantly squeezing you know it might be squeezing your lunch time it might be squeezing your start times or your finish times to get more hours in the day and so really have a look at what jobs you're doing every week and similarly supervision should ideally be in your job plan and should be a consistent, repeatable endeavour. OK, so mine certainly is. And similarly, if you're doing any meetings that you have to go to, then that should be in your job plan. And does that happen? You know, if the meeting is not that not that productive not that energetic do you need to be there every time or could you job plan it that across the team you share the load so you might go every other week or one in four um or three and four and then you know the fourth one you use as time to to do that admin know, you're not asking for the moon on a stick. As they say,
我的工作计划里肯定有。同样，如果你必须参加任何会议，那也应该在计划中。但这些会议真的有必要吗？如果会议效率不高、不够积极，你是否需要每次都参加？或者你可以通过团队分担工作，比如每两周参加一次，或者四次里参加三次，剩下的时间用来处理行政工作。你并不是在要求天上的星星，正如人们所说，
you're just asking for enough time to be able to do your job well, safely, robustly, to be able to do what you need to do. So if you're learning a particular skill or approach and you need to do reading or you're doing research, could you look at trying to include that within your job plan so certainly when I was an aspiring psychologist and I would attend assistant psychologist meetings and I would also attend research meetings then they would have been job planned if I was using job plans at that time because those job plans you know ideally are being agreed by your supervisor and or manager. They're saying, yes, those are important issues for us. So we do see that that's really important.
你只是在要求足够的时间来出色、安全、稳健地完成你的工作。所以，如果你正在学习某种技能或方法，需要阅读或研究，能否尝试将其纳入工作计划？当我还是有抱负的心理学家时，我会参加助理心理学家会议和研究会议，如果当时有工作计划的话，这些都会被列入其中。因为这些工作计划理想情况下是由你的督导或经理商定的，他们会认可这些事项对我们很重要。
And it, you know, I still use a job plan now. So I still have Monday. So I have Mondays and Fridays where I do largely admin. I do things like today's a Friday I'm doing a podcast and I do the editing around that and I might write for the media and I might create content on Mondays and Fridays for my aspiring psychologist membership and you know try to do my non-client stuff on those days but Tuesdays and Wednesdays and Thursday mornings I do do see clients. So I run clinics, I run three clinics, 9.15, 10.15 and 11.15. And that's, that's predictable and repeatable. And I always have time to do my notes in between those sessions, unless they're overly complicated. But then I make time to do that before I stop for lunch. So I don't want any leftover projects,
而且，我现在仍然使用工作计划。我周一和周五主要处理行政工作。比如今天周五，我在录播客，处理剪辑，为媒体写作，并在周一和周五为我的“有抱负的心理学家会员”创作内容。我尽量在这些天处理非客户工作。但周二、周三和周四上午，我确实会见客户。我开设了三个诊所，时间分别是9:15、10:15和11:15。这是可预测且可重复的。我总是有时间在这些会谈之间写笔记，除非情况特别复杂。但我会确保在午餐前完成这些工作，这样我就不会有遗留的项目，
you know, I want to be able to stop for lunch. And I've always stopped for lunch in whatever service I've worked in. I believe I've been told that I have a very good impact on team lunching and sociability because I always stop. So people are like, oh, Marian Marianne's there I'll sit down with her you know and we'll eat our salads together um or in my most recent NHS service I was known for chippy Tuesday so every now and then I'd be like come on let's you know there's a great chippy nearby and on a Tuesday they do a great pie um chips and sauce deal. So I would go for chicken and mushroom pie, the most amazing chips and curry sauce, and it would be like 350. And so I'd like try and get people in advance to sign up for sitting down and having Chippy Tuesday with me. And it was just really, really good. And so, you know, my lunchtime, usually 1230 till 1 when I was in NHS services was happening
我想在午餐时间休息。无论我在哪个机构工作，我总是会休息吃午餐。有人告诉我，我在团队午餐和社交方面有很好的影响，因为我总是会停下来休息。所以大家会说：“哦，玛丽安在那儿，我跟她一起坐吧，我们一起吃沙拉。”或者在我最近工作的 NHS 机构里，我以“炸鱼薯条周二”（Chippy Tuesday）而闻名。偶尔我会说：“来吧，附近有一家很棒的炸鱼薯条店，周二有很划算的派、薯条和酱汁套餐。”我会点鸡肉蘑菇派、超赞的薯条和咖喱酱，只要3.5英镑。我会提前邀请大家一起坐下来享受“炸鱼薯条周二”。这真的非常棒。所以，我在 NHS 工作时，通常在12:30到1点之间休息，
every day I was bringing my lunch with me you know I was accountable I was making that usually the evening before um so that it would nourish me for the day so I'm a salad eater generally I don't I don't eat chippy Tuesdays every Tuesday um but they were delicious and I was if I still worked there I would still be instigating Chippy Tuesday because the chips are incredible. You know, you're just a really good chippy. And if you're not listening to this in the UK and you're like, what is she saying? What is she saying? A chippy? What's a chippy? A chippy tea um so that's when i was in south wales uh my friends from um lancashire
每天我都会带午餐，我很有自律，通常前一天晚上就准备好了，这样能为我提供一天的能量。我通常吃沙拉，并不是每周二都吃炸鱼薯条，但它们确实很美味。如果我还在那里工作，我依然会发起“炸鱼薯条周二”，因为那里的薯条太棒了。如果你不是在英国收听，可能会问：“她在说什么？什么是 Chippy？”Chippy 就是炸鱼薯条店。Chippy tea 是指炸鱼薯条晚餐。我在南威尔士时，来自兰开夏郡的朋友
introduced me to the term chippy tea chippy it's a fish and chip shop um in case you're not familiar with chippy tea um did you ever think that you'd hear me talk about chippy teas and chippies so much i didn't I didn't know that was going to be my plan for today. But yeah, it's important to stop. It's important to look after yourself and to give yourself that appropriate self-care. So you need to make sure you're job planning your lunch break, job planning your start and finish times, because that helps make sure that you're not overloaded. You know, if there's a massive waiting list, then you can absolutely be moved by that distress
向我介绍了 Chippy tea 这个词。Chippy 就是炸鱼薯条店。如果你不熟悉 Chippy tea，你有没有想过会听到我谈论这么多关于炸鱼薯条的事？我之前也没想到今天会计划讲这个。但确实，停下来休息很重要，照顾好自己并进行适当的自我关怀很重要。所以你需要确保把午餐时间、开始和结束时间都列入工作计划，因为这有助于确保你不会负担过重。如果候诊名单很长，你当然会因此感到压力，
and think about what clever ways you can work in as you and as part of the team to reduce that workload. But, you know, seeing a massive amount of face-to-face clients, and I absolutely appreciate that for many of you listening certainly if you're you're listening to this working in IACT services you might well not have this flexibility so I know certain people in certain services are seeing you know 70 80 90 percent face-to-face time but that is that is gonna be very difficult to achieve long term that's gonna lead to burnout and you might just need to look at where you can factor in some self-care around that and you need
并思考作为团队的一员，你能用什么聪明的方法来减轻工作量。但是，面对大量的面对面客户——我完全理解对于许多收听节目的朋友，特别是如果你在 IAPT 服务机构工作，你可能没有这种灵活性。我知道某些机构的人员有70%、80%甚至90%的时间都在进行面对面工作，但长期来看这很难实现，会导致倦怠。你可能需要看看在这些工作之外，哪里可以安排一些自我关怀。你需要
to make sure you're having regular supervision and that you're able to talk through the impact of this level of clinical work so when I was employed in AA level, which in case you're not familiar with bandings, the NHS agenda for change bandings usually have numbers and sometimes letters to denote which level of pay you're on, which grade. So band seven is where you qualify usually when you qualify as a clinical psychologist and a counselling psychologist. And band 8A is usually a level above that. And so when I was recruited to band 8A, I was recruited to be able to do 50% face-to-face time. But when I started that role, I was told by the others in the team it's not really possible you can't really do it because you can't get the rooms and I was like I am job planning this I am doing this you want 50%
确保有定期的督导，并能够讨论这种临床工作水平带来的影响。当我受雇于 8A 级别时——如果你不熟悉职级，NHS 的“变革议程”职级通常有数字，有时还有字母来表示薪资级别。临床心理学家和咨询心理学家通常在获得资格后处于 7 级，8A 级通常比那高一级。当我被聘为 8A 级时，我被要求能够完成50%的面对面工作时间。但当我开始那个职位时，团队里的其他人告诉我：“这不太可能，你做不到，因为你找不到房间。”我说：“我正在做工作计划，我正在做这件事。你们想要50%，
you're getting 50% and I went out across the trust I saw people in a library I saw people in a health center I saw people in a different psychiatric base so So I was like, Madam Peripatetic, I was everywhere. So when I first started that role, I was four days a week. And when I went back after my second baby, I was three days a week. But when I was four days a week, I was in four different locations, five different locations, actually, because there was no rooms available in my clinic base. And so on a Tuesday afternoon I would go in into the team sit in the agile office and do my admin it was job planned that I would do my admin so that I at least saw the team whereas when I went down to three days a week it just was all
你们就会得到50%。”于是我跑遍了整个信托机构，我在图书馆见客户，在健康中心见客户，在不同的精神科基地见客户。所以我就像个“巡回医生”，到处跑。刚开始那个职位时，我每周工作四天。生完第二个孩子回来后，我每周工作三天。但每周工作四天时，我在五个不同的地点工作，因为我的诊所基地没有空房间。所以周二下午我会回到团队，坐在灵活办公区处理行政工作。我把行政工作列入计划，这样至少能见到团队成员。而当我减少到每周三天时，
that level of moving around was a bit less sustainable and so I was able to get some rooms job planned and booked in advance I would book them six months in advance on the clinical systems to make sure that I was going to be able to see those clients, support my clients, pick up new clients, and, you know, support the team and reduce the waiting list because that was really important to me. So sometimes you might well be working in a service where you are pioneering, you are wanting to do these things, but processes move slower. And maybe that might well be a conversation for another day, but it's one I'm passionate about. So let's pause here for a brief break and I'll be back along with one, two, three more strategies to help think about how to organize yourself and be just an all-around
那种到处奔波的程度稍微没那么难以维持了。所以我能够预先安排并预订一些房间，我会在临床系统上提前六个月预订，以确保我能够见到那些客户，支持我的客户，接收新客户，并支持团队，减少候诊名单，因为这对我来说非常重要。所以有时你可能在一家服务机构工作，你是先驱者，你想做这些事，但流程进展缓慢。也许这可以留到以后再讨论，但我对此充满热情。让我们在这里暂停一下，稍后我会回来，带来另外三个策略，帮助你思考如何组织自己，成为一个全方位的
superstar catch up with you very soon if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hello, my name is Avalon and I'm an undergraduate psychology student. I recently finished a year-long placement as an AP in the NHS and I'm now one week into my final year. I recently finished a year-long placement as an AP in the NHS and I'm
超级明星。很快回来。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。来看看吧，就在这本书里。《临床心理学家集体》。我是阿瓦隆（Avalon），一名心理学本科生。我最近刚结束在 NHS 为期一年的助理心理学家（AP）实习，现在是我最后一年学业的第一周。
now one week into my final year. I loved reading the Clinical Psychologist Collective and I couldn't have come across it at a better time. I was starting to panic a bit about my options after uni and reading that there are so many different paths that have ultimately led people to the clinical psychology doctorate was really reassuring. Hearing about people's amazing experiences and wide range of backgrounds has really encouraged me to follow what interests me and to make the most of the journey rather than seeing everything that I do as a step towards the doctorate. It has also really helped me to reflect on my approach to work in previous years which
我非常喜欢读《临床心理学家集体》，它出现得正是时候。我当时开始对毕业后的选择感到有些恐慌，读到有这么多不同的路径最终引导人们获得临床心理学博士学位，真的让我感到非常安心。听到人们令人惊叹的经历和广泛的背景，真的鼓励我追随自己的兴趣，充分利用这段旅程，而不是把我所做的一切都仅仅看作是通往博士学位的阶梯。它也真的帮助我反思了过去几年我的工作方式，
wasn't very healthy and now I can work on trying to get more balance and put less pressure on myself, as I know that these skills will be really important when I'm thinking about applying for the D2N Sci in a few years' time. Become a psychologist and let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. So how good is that? You absolutely don't just take my word for it um take um avalon's word for it too
那并不健康。现在我可以努力寻求更多的平衡，减少给自己的压力，因为我知道这些技能在我几年后申请临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）时会非常重要。成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。来看看吧，就在这本书里。《临床心理学家集体》。这太棒了，对吧？你绝对不应该只听我的一面之词，也要听听阿瓦隆的。
um it really is worth you checking out okay so in the first half um we were discussing job plans and how they can help you be an all-round superstar basically to be able to get what you need to get done done um so i hope you found that helpful um my next little um tip would be um when you are noticing things that you think you might want to talk about in supervision it's just to be quite honest about that with clients so um i can't reach my diary because it's just over there. But if I'm with a client, I would say, for example, OK, I'm not quite sure about that or I haven't come across that exact set of circumstances before. But what I'm going to do is I'm going to make a note for myself to take that to my next supervision session and then I'll come back with you and we'll explore that together does that sound okay don't be you know don't be afraid of saying you don't know the answer and what I would do then is I would grab my diary and I would write in the section of my diary
这真的很值得一看。好的，在上半部分，我们讨论了工作计划以及它们如何帮助你成为全方位的超级明星，基本上是为了让你能完成需要完成的事情。希望你觉得有帮助。我的下一个小建议是，当你注意到一些你想在督导中讨论的事情时，要对客户保持坦诚。比如，我够不到我的日记本，因为它在那边。但如果我和客户在一起，我会说：“好的，我不确定这一点，或者我以前没遇到过这种情况。但我会记下来，带到下一次督导中讨论，然后再回来和你一起探讨，这样可以吗？”不要害怕说你不知道答案。我会抓起我的日记本，写在
because I've got an A4 diary I would write in the section issues for supervision and so when it comes to supervision I've already got that list ready to go I'm not having to find additional time to plan in what I need to talk about now of course you might have a duty of care to discuss clients at set intervals as well but it always can be useful to go into supervision with set questions you know so you know you might I might say okay so this cropped up in a session recently and i my supervision question for this might be how can i um help this client to how can we explore this more together or how can i um you know which evidence-based treatment could i use with them to
“督导议题”那一栏。这样到了督导时，我已经准备好了清单，不需要额外花时间去计划要讨论什么。当然，你可能有义务在固定间隔讨论客户，但带着明确的问题去督导总是很有用的。比如，我可能会说：“最近会谈中出现了这种情况，我的督导问题可能是：我该如何帮助这位客户？我们如何能更深入地探讨这个问题？或者我可以使用哪种循证治疗来帮助解决这个问题？”
help shift this problem you know and I can't think of any examples off the top of my head without giving away client confidentiality but you'll know what I mean you know sometimes something comes up and you're not quite sure or you know I might say to someone it seems like you know we're not perhaps making as much progress as as we might expect have you you know have you noticed that so we might have would you discuss that that's the issue um and you know i wonder what that might be about and um what i might suggest is that i take this to supervision and we use really talking through um this this casework to make sure that we're doing everything that can possibly help advance and shape and help
我无法在不泄露客户隐私的情况下随口举例，但你会明白我的意思。有时会出现一些情况，你不确定该怎么办。或者我可能会对某人说：“看起来我们似乎没有达到预期的进展，你注意到了吗？”所以我们可能会讨论这个问题，我想知道这可能是什么原因。我可能会建议我把这个问题带到督导中，通过讨论这个案例，确保我们正在尽一切可能帮助推进和塑造，并帮助
you get the progress that you so need and you so deserve. So you're not making it sound like they're a special case. And I do say that, you know, so when I start working with a client, I will absolutely say, you know, even though I'm qualified, and I certainly used to say this when I wasn't qualified, as part of my clinical responsibilities and as part of safeguarding for clients, I have an obligation to do supervision. And what will happen during those sessions is that we'll talk about the work that we're doing together. And we'll only ever really use your first name. But I will also make a supervision record onto your notes to say what we've discussed and what the outcomes will be.
你获得你所需要的、你所应得的进展。你不需要让客户觉得他们是一个特殊的案例。我确实会这样说，当我开始与客户合作时，我绝对会说：“虽然我是有资质的——我当然在没有资质时也这么说——作为我的临床责任和客户保护的一部分，我有义务进行督导。在这些会谈中，我们会讨论我们共同开展的工作。我们只会使用你的名字。但我也会在你的笔记中记录督导记录，说明我们讨论了什么以及结果是什么。”
And if you're ever wondering what I've said in supervision or what we might be discussing, I'm absolutely OK for you to ask me that. It can be a transparent process, but I don't need to think that I'm asking my supervisor because, you know, you're a lost cause or this is, you know, you're a special case. This is something that I have an obligation to do with everybody. And so, you know, this really helps make sure that we're operating an effective and safe service. So that's why we do that. So I'm just going to make a note of that to think about anything that I might not have considered. Because sometimes when we're right in something with somebody, we can, you know, we're not seeing other options as well. So it can really help us think more holistically and think about different approaches that we might not yet have tried that might be really, really useful. So I've made a
“如果你想知道我在督导中说了什么，或者我们讨论了什么，我完全可以告诉你。这是一个透明的过程。但我不需要觉得我在问我的督导是因为你是一个‘无药可救’的案例，或者你是一个‘特殊案例’。这是我必须对每个人做的事情。所以，这真的有助于确保我们提供有效且安全的服务。这就是我们这样做的原因。所以我现在在日记里记下这一点，去思考任何我可能没考虑到的事情。因为有时当我们和某人一起处理某事时，我们可能看不到其他选择。所以这真的能帮助我们更全面地思考，并考虑我们尚未尝试过的、可能非常有用的不同方法。”所以我现在在
note of that now in my diary and I'll come back to you. So that helps you not forget what you need to do, but also uses that in the moment processing to be able to think with clients and to help them shape, to help shape the experiences. But to be really transparent as well, which is always something I've enjoyed. OK, so we are fast advancing through my top tips. And this is another approach that I use within my business, and it's something called ClickUp, ClickUp, C-L-I-C-K, up, separate words, and I use that to set myself tasks, and it's a free app, you might not be able to get it on trust computers, if you work for an NHS trust, it might be blocked as a download, you might not even be able to get
日记里记下了这一点，我会再回来找你。这不仅能帮你记住需要做的事，还能利用当下的处理过程与客户一起思考，帮助他们塑造体验。同时保持透明，这也是我一直很喜欢的。好了，我们正在快速推进我的顶级建议。这是我在业务中使用的另一种方法，叫做 ClickUp（C-L-I-C-K-U-P），我用它来给自己设定任务。这是一个免费的应用程序，你可能无法在信托机构的电脑上使用它，如果是在 NHS 信托机构工作，它可能被禁止下载，你甚至可能无法在
it on your trust phone. So there is a ClickUp app, but you should certainly be able to get it on your personal phone. Now, when you're using your personal phone, please don't put any client data in, nothing identifiable. But if you know you've got to write reports then I would for example write myself a click up task set myself as the person that needs to do it give myself the deadline for when that needs to happen or if I've job planned it I would get that to pop up a point when I'm supposed to be writing it as a reminder and I would say write report from and then the date you know of the assessment so you're not giving away any identifiable data and similarly even if you're using that on your trust or your organization computers
工作手机上安装它。但你肯定可以在个人手机上安装。现在，使用个人手机时，请不要输入任何客户数据，不要输入任何可识别信息。但如果你知道必须写报告，我会给自己设定一个 ClickUp 任务，把自己设为执行人，给自己设定截止日期，或者如果我把它列入了工作计划，我会让它在预定写作时间弹出提醒。我会写：“撰写评估报告，日期是……”，这样你就不会泄露任何可识别数据。同样，即使你在信托机构或组织的电脑上使用它，
it still makes sense to use that anonymously so yeah the way you do that is you set the deadline and then it will it will come up but it will also come up in your task list so if you suddenly find that you've got a DNA someone hasn't attended session, then you can just go to your task list and try and pick the task that you think you've got that fits that time so that you're using any dead time really, really usefully. And I also used to use, this reminded me, I also used to use sticky notes, which you will be able to get on your NHS computers or your organisation computers. If you just go to the search magnifying function at the bottom and put in sticky notes, it's like little post-it notes that stay attached to your desktop. So I would write myself lists when I was in the NHS of jobs I needed to do. And then, yeah, I would pick how much time I had and I would do them.
匿名使用也是合理的。所以，你设定截止日期，它就会弹出提醒，也会出现在你的任务列表中。如果你突然发现有客户没来（DNA），你就可以直接去任务列表，挑选你认为适合那段时间的任务，这样你就能非常有效地利用任何空闲时间。我以前也用过便利贴（Sticky Notes），你可以在 NHS 或组织的电脑上找到它。如果你点击底部的搜索放大镜功能，输入“Sticky Notes”，它就像贴在桌面上的小便利贴。我在 NHS 工作时会用它给自己列出需要做的任务清单。然后，我会根据我有多少时间来选择完成它们。
So, yeah, that's part of my super efficiency is to make sure that I'm using all of the job planned time. But any extra time that comes up, I am also using to the best of my ability too and my final little productivity tip is another free app so all of the above information applies about confidentiality and not disclosing things you shouldn't within a non-nhs non-encrypted app but slack is an app So if I need to remind myself to do something, I will set myself a reminder in Slack. So I'll write myself a message in my DMs, my direct messages in Slack, and then I'll set myself a reminder so that it comes up to do that. And you can probably do the same in your Outlook calendar as well, if you use that for work. So you can set yourself reminders of things you need to do and when I was using Outlook for my NHS work I would use that as job plan so I would colour code because my job plan was always colour coded I would colour code my clinics so I would have a 9.15 a 10.15
所以，这是我超级效率的一部分，确保我利用了所有计划好的工作时间。但任何额外出现的时间，我也在尽我所能地利用。我最后一个生产力小贴士是另一个免费应用程序——Slack。所有关于保密性和不在非加密应用程序中披露不该披露的信息的原则同样适用。Slack 是一个应用程序，如果我需要提醒自己做某事，我会给自己设定一个 Slack 提醒。我会给自己发一条私信，然后设定一个提醒，这样它就会弹出提醒我去做。如果你在工作中使用 Outlook 日历，你可能也可以做同样的事情。你可以给自己设定提醒。我在 NHS 工作时使用 Outlook 作为工作计划，我会进行颜色编码，因为我的工作计划总是颜色编码的。我会给诊所进行颜色编码，比如9:15、10:15
and 11.15 even when I was in the NHS on my clinic days and they would always be green and I'd have them as recurring appointments in my diary so I could see where my blank spaces were and then next to it if I booked a client I would create an additional green a green session appointment for the same time 9 15 to 10 0 5 and then I would be able to see quickly where I had spaces available and where I didn't because I wanted to where I had spaces available and where I didn't because I wanted to be running a fully booked system where I didn't have spaces because that is the way to be efficient that is the way to get clients advancing towards their goals more quickly so how has that been for you I hope you you found that useful. I would love to know
和11:15，即使在 NHS 工作时，在诊所日，它们总是绿色的。我会把它们设为日历中的重复预约，这样我就能看到哪里有空档。然后旁边如果我预约了客户，我会为同一时间（9:15到10:05）创建一个额外的绿色会谈预约。这样我就能快速看到哪里有空位，哪里没有。因为我想运行一个满额预约系统，没有空位，因为那是提高效率的方法，那是让客户更快朝着目标前进的方法。那么，这对你来说感觉如何？希望你觉得有用。我很想知道
what your take-home messages were from this and whether it's invoked any thinking for you and whether it might be useful. And I'd love you to come along to the Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community, brackets, free group, which is my free community for helping aspiring psychologists. Also wanted to say that we've got a compassionate Q&A happening at 7.30pm on Monday, the 31st of October, and that will be running across all of my socials. So come and like them all, won't you? Dr. Marianne Trent, pretty much everywhere. It won't be on TikTok because I don't think I can manage to stream to TikTok at the same time as streaming everywhere else. But it will be on Twitter, on YouTube, on Facebook, on LinkedIn and Instagram.
你从中学到了什么，它是否引发了你的思考，以及它是否可能有用。我很希望你加入我们的 Facebook 群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community，免费群组），这是我为帮助有抱负的心理学家建立的免费社区。我还想说，我们将在10月31日周一晚上7:30进行一场“同情心问答”（Compassionate Q&A），届时将在我所有的社交媒体上直播。所以，去关注它们吧，好吗？到处都是“Dr. Marianne Trent”。TikTok 上可能不会有，因为我觉得我无法同时在 TikTok 和其他平台直播。但它会在 Twitter、YouTube、Facebook、LinkedIn 和 Instagram 上进行。
That's the plan anyway. If you're going to be watching on Twitter, for some reason, they don't allow the comments to come through to the live broadcast. So if you have got questions, you might well want to watch from one of the other platforms because all of those comments and questions will come through there. But if you just want to tune in and watch, then you can do that via Twitter. But on the night itself, I'll remind you that if you're commenting via Twitter, I won't see you, unfortunately. But I'll know you're there because it will come up in my viewers. But I won't be able to see your comments until I look later on Twitter. So even then, I don't think the comments get kept on the live broadcast on Twitter. Come on, Twitter, sort yourselves out.
计划就是这样。如果你打算在 Twitter 上观看，出于某种原因，他们不允许评论出现在直播中。所以如果你有问题，你可能想在其他平台观看，因为所有的评论和问题都会在那里显示。但如果你只是想收看，可以通过 Twitter。但在当晚，我会提醒你，如果你通过 Twitter 评论，很遗憾我看不见。但我会知道你在那里，因为你会出现在我的观众列表中。但我直到稍后查看 Twitter 时才能看到你的评论。即便如此，我觉得 Twitter 直播结束后评论也不会保留。拜托，Twitter，整理一下你们的系统吧。
You know, girl's trying to run a business here. So, yeah, I hope you found that really useful. If you'd welcome some additional support during this psychology application season or beyond, please do consider joining us in the aspiring psychologist membership because the reviews i'm getting about how wonderfully enriching it is how we're helping people learn more about cbt how we're helping learn more about personal and professional issues how we're helping increase people's confidence to talk about themselves and to be reflective and learn about different psychological approaches. You know, it's good stuff. Someone said to me the other day, I love Marianne Mondays, you know,
你知道，我在这里经营着一家企业。所以，是的，我希望你觉得这些内容很有用。如果你在这次心理学申请季或之后需要额外的支持，请考虑加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划。我收到的反馈都说这个计划非常充实，我们帮助人们学习更多关于CBT的知识，帮助他们了解个人和职业问题，帮助他们增强谈论自己、进行反思以及学习不同心理学方法的信心。你知道，这真的很棒。前几天有人对我说，我喜欢“玛丽安周一”，你知道，
because our stuff usually happens on a Monday, you know, and she was telling her parents about Marianne Mondays. And I just thought it's really, really nice, you know, being able to impact on people's lives in this way is just the greatest privilege and I'm having a blast doing it so thank you so much for listening if you do like what you hear please do like and subscribe if you're watching on YouTube please do subscribe to the channel um fling me a couple of comments on the episodes it's so gratefully received if you're listening on um Apple Podcasts please do subscribe, follow on Spotify, and write me a little review of the podcast on Apple Podcasts would be so wonderful. Thank you so much. This is episode 45, which means we're fast approaching a whole year of the Aspiring
因为我们的活动通常在周一进行，你知道，她还跟她父母提到了“玛丽安周一”。我当时就觉得这真的非常好，你知道，能够以这种方式影响人们的生活是最大的荣幸，而且我乐在其中，所以非常感谢你们的收听。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请点赞并订阅。如果你是在YouTube上观看，请订阅我们的频道，嗯，在剧集下给我留几条评论，我会非常感激。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请订阅，在Spotify上关注，并为我的播客写一条简短的评论，那将是非常棒的。非常感谢。这是第45集，这意味着我们很快就要迎来“有抱负的心理学家”播客的一周年纪念了。
Psychologist podcast. What a privilege. What a privilege that you're still listening. You're still finding it useful. You're liking the jingles. You're going out for your dog walks. You're running your, you know, running your show and finding a way to get me in it too. So thank you so much for being part of my world.
心理学家播客。这是一种荣幸。你们还在收听，还在觉得它有用，还在喜欢这些片头曲，这真是一种荣幸。你们在遛狗时，在忙自己的事情时，还能找到时间听我的节目。所以非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分。
I will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Take care. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a
我期待很快与你们再次交流。保重。这是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的不同故事非常有趣。令我惊讶的是，通往这一目标的途径竟然如此之多，没有所谓的完美路径，这让我充满了信心，让我觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名
clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始读，就停不下来了。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。